le port du masque constitue avec le
respect des gestes dits barrière une
mesure de prévention et de protection
efficace j'ai donc proposé que
l'obligation de le porter soit renforcée
dans tous les établissements recevant du
public
clo en particulier ce qui n'est pas le
cas aujourd'hui les commerces
cela nécessite un décret alors que dans
les locaux dits professionnels
cela suppose une évolution des
protocoles sanitaires régissant les
activités concernées nous envisagions
une entrée en vigueur de ces
dispositions le premier route parce
qu'encore une fois nous agissons dans
une logique préventive est pas seul
empire de l'urgence j'ai entendu et
compris que cette échéance
à paris c'est tardive ou susciter
quelques interrogations
le décret entrera donc en vigueur la
semaine prochaine il est demandé
j'ai demandé par ailleurs aux ministres
chargés de la santé de l'éducation
nationale l'enseignement supérieur de
donner très rapidement des indications
précises aux familles au corps
enseignant sur les conditions dans
lesquelles se déroulera la rentrée de
septembre dans les établissements
d'enseignement
[Musique]